everybody you guys have been asking for
an infinity war update they just
confirmed a whole bunch of wakanda stuff
that they're filming right now in
surprise surprise look who showed up the
Hulk so I will explain the wakandan
Hulkbuster from the comics yes you heard
that right black panther has his own
Hulkbuster it's made out of vibranium
they have crazy advanced technology of
course they're going to have
countermeasures for the Hulk so why
don't we bring the Hulkbuster giveaway
back it'll be for the Iron Man
Hulkbuster but you get the idea all you
have to do to enter just be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video sweep
sweep go to sleep and when I say they're
filming Wakanda scenes right now there's
a whole bunch of stuff happening but
let's start with the big stuff banner
sharing scenes with T'Challa now this
isn't necessarily means that he'll be
hooked because he doesn't have the dots
on his face but this just confirms that
he's already back on earth and because
he's persona non grata in the United
States
he's a Megaton nuke as described by
general Ross Charlie Chaplin do you know
where Thor and banner are right now if I
misplaced a couple of 30 Megaton he's
probably going to try and spend as much
time with his out of the country friends
as possible so we can also talk about
how Tony Stark is going to try and
recruit Black Panther for the Avengers
initiative because even though he fought
on his team during civil war does not
mean that he's part of the Avengers he's
rich enough that he could fund his own
Avengers team all by himself without any
of Iron Man's help but I know there's
all kinds of questions about how does he
get back to earth what happens after
thor ragnarok there's so many things
that haven't happened yet we don't know
what black panthers doing after the
Black Panther movie even though that's
the last movie for infinity war so
whatever is going to be set up on the
earth that's going to be happening at
the end of that movie and I think we can
just assume based on the course of
events that Hulk and Thor will set
things right or relatively right because
Ragnarok is such a big concept in the
Thor comics it's literally like a cycle
of death and rebirth where some of the
gods die and get reborn some of them
live on it's sort of like a retooling of
the universe on a very cosmic level but
it looks like they're localizing most of
that to Asgard so any of the
repercussions of Ragnarok will probably
be referenced by people like Tony Stark
on earth but it's not like some
blast wave is going to come and I'll eat
everything that's really where you get
into fan OHS Infinity Gauntlet things
that's where you're effecting things on
a universal scale so let's just assume
as of the end of thor ragnarok that hook
makes it back to planet earth but he's
still not on good terms with anybody in
the united states so like at the
beginning of the Avengers movie when
they first recruited him well he was
trying to keep a low profile as possible
I got paid up front banner you know man
exposed to be avoiding stress he picked
a hell of a place to settle
I've learning stress in the secret and
what is it yoga you brought me the edge
of the city smart but the really cool
thing is that now that we have black
panther and they've sort of opened the
doors on Wakanda to outside people is
that black panther is sort of a stealth
science bro that you never knew about
people like Sheree who've already been
confirmed to be Tony Stark level
geniuses there's all that going on in
Wakanda so it's this place of learning
in science
why wouldn't Banner go there if he
needed somewhere to hide out so just
assuming for now that most of their
infinity war scenes are a lot like what
you saw Tony in banner doing at the
beginning of Avengers age of Ultron
they've been sharing lab space and
science pros so what we saw at the end
of Captain America Civil War we have
Winter Soldier we have Captain America
we see all these scientists running
around in the background so there's just
a lot of extra lab space in Wakanda the
banner could take advantage of is there
studying things so this is all separate
from what's happening in infinity war
because the whole idea of that movie
just trying to squeeze as many
references in as possible
he saw the vision that Scarlet Witch
gave him of the [ __ ] our invasion the
destruction of everything this right
here is the thing that they teased in
that infinity war teasers that they
dropped earlier this year you're looking
at the vision the Tony Stark had only it
seems like it's playing out again so
what it sounds like is happening is that
we're just going to revisit that Tony
Stark nightmare but this is sanctuary
the place where Thanos has thrown was
during guardians of the galaxy he knows
something's coming he doesn't know
exactly what they nose is yet so he goes
around recruiting all the Avengers Black
Panther is still dealing with what's
happening at the end of his movie
cementing his rule as well as his role
as black panther because that's the
whole idea being a good man but also
being a king and being the black panther
this Avengers level hero so like you've
seen me use this black panther picture
where he wields the Infinity Gauntlet
from Secret Wars the big comic book
event a couple years ago I think he's
one of the most likely candidates for
wielding the Infinity Gauntlet like him
Captain Marvel or spider-man because you
give the kid the ultimate power he needs
the ultimate responsibility there's just
so much fun that you can have with that
but if there's going to be anybody to
wield the gauntlet it will be the most
responsible most secure person and it
just feels like that's what Black
Panthers movie is all about is securing
his identity as well as his ability to
lead other people as for the two of them
actually fighting each other Hulk and
Black Panther there have been a couple
times they've gone at it in the Avengers
comics going all the way back to the
classic lineup but during the recent
civil war run they put black panther in
a wakandan hulk buster
so just like the Iron Man Hulkbuster is
designed to counteract the Hulk's powers
but they learn about a couple new twists
so this version actually takes the
Hulk's power amplifies it and feeds it
back into him so it's like this giant
feedback loop because the matter the
hole gets the stronger he gets the more
force he exerts on Black Panthers Hulk
Buster the more power it stores up and
feeds back at him but the whole idea is
that the Hulk's rage is a limitless so
vibranium Hulk Buster is still no match
for the Hulk in in addition to that
there's a lot of circuitry inside and we
learn that the Hulk has the new
abilities we haven't seen before where
he gives off gamma radiation as he gets
madder and madder but is a consequence
of that like the next logical step is
that he can give off an EMP so as he
gets madder and madder like the field of
gamma around him grows and just Fries
electronic circuits so that is why no
matter which Hulk Buster you use Iron
Man's Hulk Buster or Black Panthers Hulk
buster you will always lose unless you
can get the hope to calm down but
because this is infinity war what you
want to see is whole fight Thanos and in
the comics they did fight during the
infinity event Thanos still put him down
for the count but not after who gave it
to him pretty good it's almost like him
soaking a full blast from Black Bolt
like he screams right in his face Thanos
eats it like it's no big
like he cracks a couple teeth and that's
about it so that is how powerful vanos
is without the Infinity Gauntlet he has
the deviance gene so he has a lot of his
own natural abilities it's sort of like
dark side without the anti-life equation
both very powerful beings in their own
right but then on top of that they gain
extra power that just makes them
Universal big bads that nobody is able
to fight so what I'm expecting for most
of these scenes that they're teasing
here is that they'll just tease them
preparing for the threat the Avengers
movie is a good example that Yuri
watched some of those scenes from before
he changes into the Hulk for most of the
movie he's just banner and this was Mark
Ruffalo's first time as the Hulk so
you're like when is he going to turn
when is he going to turn we've seen it
in the trailer but sure enough as you're
entering the third act of the film boom
he blows up and starts wrecking the
inside of that Helicarrier
so let me know hoax hanging out in
Wakanda what else do you want him to do
while he's there will he study more
gamma radiation will he learn things
from black panther and obviously Dana
guerreras character as part of this -
they just confirmed that she was in the
infinity war cast they'll be in Wakanda
so of course all those Black Panther
characters will show up but because the
film is going to be jumping around to
places like you've seen all the stuff
that's happening in Scotland with vision
and Scarlet Witch they've been filming
in that big Cathedral where it seems
like everybody's going there's only
going to be spending a portion of the
movie in Wakanda or any of these other
places so it's not like they're going to
have everybody from the Black Panther
movie but either way is going to be
badass we'll probably see our first
teaser at Comic Con hopefully they
released that publicly sometimes they
only show for Hall age they did that
with guardians of the galaxy last year
but another really big cosmic news they
just confirmed that Jessica Chastain is
going to be the villain of the x-men
Dark Phoenix movie now they quoted her
is playing lilandra and she's
technically not a villain so I think
they're just using the term villain in a
very broad sense she's more of an
antagonist but I'm so excited
I bet Lauren Shuler Donner just text her
to this picture and asked her if she was
in yeah totally in but I'll do a video
about that next because it just confirms
that they are going full Shiar empire
which i think is a good move for the
x-men universe but I'll just continue
the giveaway when I post that video so
I'll announce the winner when I post
that so that'll be later tonight should
be up in a couple hours
while you wait for that you can click
here to rewatch the black panther
trailer and you can click here for brand
new flash thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you
tonight
you